would you like cigarette flavored
coffee hey you know what there are
something
Cino Cino
[Music]
dude all right we're going to talk about
smoking all right I'm going to give you
guys some stats and then we're going to
try it's scary know did you used to
smoke like
this what the wow that's kind of hot
afod my nipples got hard that's a that's
a that's a leftover cigarette can you do
that again that's how to make the
cigarette
come can now remove your
hand that was a cigarette right there I
like these one by one instructions as it
keeps happening so here I'm going to
give you some stats first and then I'm
going to tell you what we're really
talking about all right so in year 2000
one in three people on Earth was a
smoker wao I've noticed that no one's
smoking cigarettes no more yeah in 2022
I kind of miss seeing people one in
every five people are smokers a big
decline yeah big decline according to
the world World Health Organization
there's uh 150 countries that have
successfully reduced their tobacco
prevalence but six countries have had a
rise which ones do you think those are
oh six okay six
countries I would say somewhere in
Africa India oh that was my yes Vietnam
yeah I'll say Vietnam southeast Asia
what about Mexico Republic of Congo is
one ah I was right Africa you said a
continent two African countries
Indonesia is oh yeah three African
countries Jordan is another one Middle
Eastern country oh yeah and then mdova
and Oman Oman these are the only six
countries where like smoking went
up because they don't have access to
Vapes
do you guys think smoking looks pretty
cool hell yeah yeah dude if it didn't
[__] up my
lungs I would smoke all the time and I
feel like SM I be smoking right now
smoking is a cool ass luxury y it's just
really bad for you it's just like
there's just no upside to doing it
except for looking really cool and and
get the edge off bro kicking it with the
boys yeah kicking it with the boys is
nice my first cigar last week and I
looked so lame doing it cuz I didn't
know what I was doing were you doing it
like this no like
this the first tip is you don't hold a
cigar like
this she's like why was I deep throating
my cigar he's like how deep in do I need
to smoke
this he's one of the guys that puts his
whole mouth on it oh you do that oh do
you want to share here your turn no you
don't share cigars dude don't you have
to get the whole thing wet tip to tip
get the wet to tip yeah the whole thing
it's ready to go now I don't know why it
won't light now I'm guessing cigars
stats is way different oh yeah cigar
stats doesn't even count no one cares
about cigar stats I like cigars no not
like that let's let's consider this so
tobacco is down by 25% in the last 15
years so the World Health Organization
has a massive fear that the tobacco
industry is gearing up for a big return
because they're they need to make a
comeback right what what what do you
think they have to do to get smoking
back up let's like think of ways that
they let's predict how they're going to
do it so like actual tobacco right not
like Vape where they have like nicotine
actual big tobacco as a as a
conglomerate movies what about
influencers do you think do you think
that would make sense for like an
influencer to start smoking cigarettes
like for brand deals yeah that's what I
mean for these for these companies to
reach out to influencers because like
who has the most everyone's attention
it's probably influencers but then like
influencers are also doing anti-smoking
stuff but that's the other thing though
too is like is like would that ruin
someone's personal brand if they just
started smoking find studies that prove
that tobacco is now good for your health
that's what they used to do yeah they
used to do that they can bring it back
dude same they had doctors remember back
in the day there's black and white
footage of doctors going like physician
approved physician approved that clean
smoke flavor yeah maybe they just pivot
a little bit and just change some of the
chemical compounds within their yeah now
it's healthy now improves their health
vaping is still considered part of the
tobacco comp yeah because vaping was
still nicotine but because it wasn't as
much like smoke it wasn't like tarring
your lungs in the same way but it picked
up like crazy but still cancerous as
[__] you know what I think they should
double down on on hookah oo so you know
hookah is cultural right like a lot of
the like places they'll they they still
do it it's like a family thing kids
adults whatever so if you make that if
you could spread that more yeah but that
might be such like a small percentage
and it doesn't have the stigmatism of
like cigarettes I saw this one um Tik
Tok it was like a a middle eastern lady
and then you know how sometimes they do
these super like aesthetic [__]
cooking things this lady was busting out
a whole set of like snacks and [__]
food and everything just for a hookah
session and if she was like prepping
that [__] I was like [__] I miss hookah
and I never did it like this like you
know like when they when you see do the
Turkish coffee oh in the hot sand oh
yeah just make it a whole thing dude but
I'm guessing like imagine how many
billions and trillions of dollars were
spent on people just like quickly
getting a cigarette taking a smoke you
can't like you can't take your [__]
smoke break and set up a hookah Cole and
[__] put hookah kits in all costos
that thing will go you know where they
[__] up is they should have just
copied Japan's cigarette success and
made flavored cigarettes that are like
dude in Japan they have these like
popping flavors like Boba no it's like
they have these little bulbs on the
filter and then you can have a regular
cigarette and then you pop it and it
turns Menthol and you pop it and it
tastes like fruit punch and then you pop
it again and it tastes like orange cream
yeah that's I think cigarettes were
created do to be convenient right
because before that it was pipes and
cigars that took too much work so they
made a cigarette to be more convenient
it was technology but then that's vaping
now Vape became more convenient than
cigarette so I feel like they're just
going to double down on vaping cuz it's
like there's no point everyone does it
still constantly like people just can't
stop sucking that thing down well they
they they should sponsor Dave Chappelle
you know how he's always smoking on
stage and he doesn't give a [__] but
that [__] makes smoking look
cool yeah really cool it makes me want
to smoke I don't know why and he has
that raspy
voice what other I'm never going back to
cigarettes what other effects his
tobacco have like can you make Salon
pass out of [__] tobacco like tobacco
make paper you can make paper yeah yeah
yeah yeah make a rope may there's
something really good about cigarettes
and coffee though there's some that
combination is like the best breakfast
it's almost the same thing to me like in
a way like real coffee and a cigarette
it's yeah it's like in the teeth
whitening cigarettes oh [__] energy
cigarettes that's good sounds expensive
energy cigarettes are like Airborne like
zinc or [__] vitamin C cigarett
multivitamin cigarettes how do you
offset what about the lung cancer aspect
though that you can knock bro no you can
create some sort of filter that will
filter out the cancer or something you
think so Tobacco For
Dogs your dog stressed out smoke them
out a little bit take the edge
off your dog always barking is your dog
whining too much here Tobacco For Dogs
dude I think they're pivoting too so
because Vapes are going to take over but
they're going to transition towards
marijuana cuz I'm I'm told that they're
buying out fields for marijuana and so
they're they're prepping for something
like that to take over the mariju just
do ghetto Style mix Weed with
tobacco spliff right sweet it gives you
a [__] head high though dude black
and miles are the best smell like
smoking smell it the plastic tips you as
Joe jitsukawa what would uh big tobacco
have to do to get you back as a customer
I don't like I don't like the after
feeling so I smoke a good cigarette and
it feels good but then after I get kind
of tired or like weird easiest way is to
just [__] hook him up with a bunch of
exstasy cuz then he's going to start
chain smoking like crazy and that's what
get that's what's almost half of my
friends who were dropping back in the
day they got into cigarettes because
they would chain smoking cigarettes out
ra and stuff yeah and then and then when
you're done rolling stuff you still got
that that need for the nicotine so
you'll just smoke casually and then
that's how people got addicted to
cigarettes it makes your lungs feel
light have you guys do you guys ever
take uh like nicotine supplements or
anything like that what that's a
supplement yeah the zims dude I guess
you wouldn't call it like nicotine
pre-workout they have like nicotine
toothpicks have you guys had oh yeah
yeah like like tea tree ones almost
because that's that's what helps people
quit let me tell you cuz you're supposed
to still like subtly take your nicotine
hit while taking away like the tar and
the smoke aspect of the cigarette so
wains you out but then people are people
abuse everything I think it's the the
the movement and the habitual like act
of the act of deep breathing is very
nice too it's
like I don't think I'll ever go back to
cigarettes I smoked that [__] for
[__] 25 years man nothing can win you
back huh no and when you quit it was
like how did it feel to quit it was a
crazy feeling because a lot of the
things that I had that were health
issues I didn't know was caused by
cigarettes I didn't even know I had
health issues cuz you just [__] SM
what if it what if it looks like a
cigarette it hits like a cigarette but
it's vapor and there's no nicotine and
there's health benefits why would you
want an invisible
[__] and it doesn't even feel good
it's
confusion but it does feel good A plus b
equals
9 I think I missed the actual Taste of
everything it's like nothing is act as
good as the actual thing would you like
cigarette flavored
[Music]
coffee that would be crazy hey you know
what there are
Cino Chino dude
Cino that sounds derogatory as [__]
don't call a person that it sounds
really bad for
Cino it sounds like a
slur
[Music]